vielen dank der älteste abgeordnete hier
im zwanzigster deutschen bundestag das
ist alexander gauland wir haben ihn
natürlich zu einem interview angefragt
er hat abgelehnt freundlicherweise hat
sein kollege albrecht glaser zugesagt
ist nämlich der zweitälteste abgeordnete
auch von der afg 79 jahres darf man
verraten herr glaser sie sind ja auch
kein ganz unbekannter denn sie haben mal
als bundestagspräsident
kandidiert jetzt vor vier jahren genau
bei dieser sitzung bundes 80 zu bringen
und als bundespräsident das wollte ich
eigentlich sagen aber es war sicherlich
so ist es also zwei mal kandidiert
zweimal durchgefallen dennoch haben sie
immer noch mehr sitzfleisch hier wieder
zu sein ist politik so eine art sucht
oder was leitet sie das hier immer noch
in dem durchaus hohen alter weiter
machen wollen naja also in der tat mit
sitzfleisch hat es glaube ich in weniger
zu tun
aber mein lebensweg ist gekennzeichnet
dadurch dass ich schon ganz früh als
jugendlicher mich wahnsinnig für politik
interessiert habe ihn aber trotzdem
nicht in eine jugendorganisation einer
partei damals angetreten und wenn dann
zu meiner eigenen verblüffung er im
kommunalen raum also als kommunaler
wahlbeamter als bürgermeister und
stadtkämmerer der stadt frankfurt oder
in anderen funktionen gewesen und habe
als schüler man schon sehen wenn ich
groß bin gehe ich im bundestag na ja und
da bin ich jetzt ich hab so ein bisschen
verspätet eingelöst das versprechen aber
es steht es waren glaube ich 42 jahre in
der cdu wie viele andere dampf
ausgetreten und dann in die afg nie
bereut ich bin mit gründer dieser idee
und habe aus ganz tiefen politischen
gründen und einsichten heraus das
projekt afd aufgesetzt wir hatten das
jahr zwei 11 212 wir hatten die
griechenland krise wir hatten eine eu
die sich entwickeln zu einem hegemann
europa der ganz direkt den angriff auf
die demokratien der europäischen
nationalstaaten macht und diese
entwicklung von knüpft mit dem euro und
einer abstrusen währungspolitik war das
motiv diese partei zu gründen dieses
motiv und auch ihre motive als idee
finde ich komme auch heute hier gar
nicht so drüber weil sie immer
provozieren die ard legt immer wert auf
provokation herr baumann folgen mit
gehörigem das war übrigens ein uralter
spruch den hat er vor vier jahren auch
schon eingebracht und die anderen
fraktionen sind richtig hoch gegangen
oder auch der vergleich mit willy brandt
mehr demokratie wagen das sind alles so
provokationen wo ich mich immer frage
warum macht die afd das warum arbeitet
die afc nicht klar an der sache und sagt
wie sie es richtig empfinden sondern sie
will immer auffallen und provozieren
naja dieses pauschale urteil mit allem
respekt kann ich so nicht stehen lassen
beispielsweise hat die afg einwahl
gesetzentwurf für die bundestagswahl
vorgelegt in dem alles drin steht auf
was wir vielleicht noch demnächst kommen
man hätte ihn nur abstimmen müssen und
hätte dann 558 abgeordnete gehabt vor
der wahl und nach der wahl und der liegt
als gesetzentwurf bis zum letzten punkt
und komma vor die afg hat vorgelegt
eingesetzt war an allen diesen
aktivitäten dankenswerter weise
beteiligt hat vorgelegten gesetzentwurf
die neuordnung das wesen der politischen
stiftungen um das in ein juristisches
kleid zu geben und mal von 600 millionen
pro jahr für diese zweite parteien
feelazur herunterzukommen auf ein
drittel das liegt als durch formulierter
gesetzentwurf da und so könnte jedoch
vieles aufzählen des deshalb mit allem
respekt wenn ein linker sich hinstellt
und uns zur nazi nachfolgeorganisation
mag er würde ich mal sagen das ist
provokation in anständiger weise
diese seltsame frage aus einem
alterspräsidenten ein dienst
alterspräsidenten zu machen das ist dann
doch schon ein etwas salopper umgang mit
demokratie
vielen dank dass sie da waren
zweitälteste abgeordnete hier im
deutschen bundestag vielen dank